[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
hello everybody how you doing this is
Lord pdtv here to give you a little info
a little a little tidbit a little snag
of uh information from uh this game
called
Zombie cure lab uh it's from uh
therabites uh we were able to be given
this key uh so I wanted to take a little
bit of time to play it so I I played
through the demo on it and it was a lot
of fun uh first of all I want to make
sure you know I'll make sure you hit
that subscribe button here uh and make
sure you check us out uh on uh also on
Twitch and on every other social media
platform
um now as for this game I wanted to talk
to you a little bit about it now
um as you can see through the video
what's going to end up happening is
you're going to end up being a a
scientist in charge of some a location
called Moose Labs where I should say an
employee of moose Labs who's been sent
out to find a cure for zombies using
the area that you're uh that you brought
in with the assistance from moose labs
and your other facilities now what we
end up doing here in uh this we end up
going through the tutorial and it kind
of teaches you how to build how to move
how to craft how to do all of those
things you need to do to kind of get you
started in the game and once you get
that started in the game they tell you
hey you can go and try other locations
so I tried a a normal difficulty level
and I was getting my butt kicked left
and right
um I don't know if I'm probably more
than likely made a lot of wrong
decisions right from the start but I
will say this it was very very
interesting to see how everything
operated it went through now the thing
the thing that made this really really
cool is that the graphics on was super
clean and super fun uh the load times
are really really cool
um the night and day cycles I really
really enjoyed
um the controls were very similar more
to most other types of Builder games
with your wasted keys and your rotations
and your buildings and things like that
which I really really thought was very
cool now um
I thought that the difficulty was very
hard but once again I went from the
tutorial to a normal which I normally
end up doing in most of these types of
games but this one I had to make sure I
did properly kind of go through and see
how it went now if you're if you're you
know you're watching this uh what you
end up doing is throughout the whole
entire game is you're trying to find
this cure for zombies now you end up
doing that by freezing the zombies and
then putting them through a treatment
process the treatment process kind of
makes them easier to deal with I guess
you can say uh to make them more of your
friends so you're going to end up using
them and recruiting them to do more um
you know
low-class type jobs like moving things
or doing something like that now after a
while what I ended up doing is I end up
taking those workers and I end up using
them in other facilities and things like
that to make them work now what was
really really nice about that was the
fact that
after you put them through the treatment
process four times they turn human again
which is really awesome because you
always use more humans in your in your
group now the the largest issue I found
with this was I I pretty much screwed up
how to maintain and keep those I think
they're called um Humvees
and relaxed and chilled I think I missed
that portion of the game properly when I
was going through this tutorial because
they kept getting angry they kept
pissing everything off they kept
breaking things and I was just like oh I
was so angry
um about that stuff but I think I I kind
of missed that portion of it but the
waves was really really cool how they
ended up doing that the waves pretty
much brought in different portions of
the zombies and you have you know your
light wave your medium wave even your
your boss waves to come in and you end
up having to deal with them and they're
all different difficulties and
eventually they end up just breaking
through my front door and I was just and
they probably pretty much took over my
base to the portion where
I had to call back to Moose labs and get
more stuff sent so they ended up sending
you supplies and things like that so you
can keep going which is actually a
really really good change in something I
really really liked is that you could
end up using that as a way to push
yourself forward so I thought that was
pretty cool so
anyway once again my name is Lord pdtv
me personally I'm on Twitch every single
Monday through Friday on my twitch
channel uh please if you want to go over
there and hit that follow button I would
appreciate it I also have Twitter uh and
Discord and all that fun stuff
um and I'm here on the iron Lords
podcast to kind of give you all a little
bit of information about zombie cure
Labs which they asked us to play so
please make sure you end up going to uh
check those guys out every single Sunday
and every single day if you're looking
for more information of games and things
that are going on please make sure Lords
of gaming.net please go check those guys
out they work very hard on those
articles they work all the time trying
to think of new things to tell you and
inform you of and I try to stay up to
date of everything that's going on and
like I said about the iron Lords podcast
make sure you guys check those guys out
they tell you guys what you need to know
about the gaming lifestyle and what's
going on they get really really cool
guys to get a lot of really cool things
going on so please make sure you go
check those guys out once again Laura
pdtv's here and I will tell you see you
all later have a good one peace
[Music]
I don't know how I'm able to just go
there and claim the reward but
okay
lava lamp
s
what we'll do here is
put the door there also so forces them
to go there
next after that
all walls must be next to the room's
floor
okay
I think that's everything but the
storage unit
oh and these guys here
foreign
zombies
[Music]
foreign
zombie attack a big one tonight
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oh yeah
I got so much of this fix and I just
realized
what's going on and I didn't realize
that we can like
continue to get supplies from these boys
a couple of days which is nice I assume
it's coming from the other facility
because
nothing's out there now great cool
I was just taking so freaking long
almost taking all of it
foreign
it did
[Music]
thank you
like these guys are
foreign
like this is brutal
[Music]
it's actually worse than what I thought
it was going to be originally
foreign
[Music]
kind of stuff for no reason
because your time frame here
so annoying
we got pissed off dude over here
breaking stuff I
I am at a loss right now I have no idea
what to do
to fix any of this
foreign
[Music]